da geht es wieder um deutsche Politik
inländische Politik es geht um das
Kurzarbeitergeld das wurde nun schon
wiederholt
erleichter zugänglich gemacht und die
ampelfraktionen wollen hier mit einem
Gesetzentwurf dafür sorgen dass es auch
bis Mitte kommenden Jahres einen
vereinfachten Zugang zum Kurzarbeiter
Geld gibt und das ist dort auch
Vereinfachungen gibt zum Beispiel was
die Prüfung der Voraussetzungen
angeht natürlich hat dort die aktuelle
Lage dafür den
ist die aktuelle Lage dafür zuständig
einerseits der Ukraine Krieg und auch
natürlich die Ungewissheit wie es in der
corona-pandemie weitergeht und deswegen
wurde hier eingesetzt Entwurf vorgelegt
über den nach ca 40 Minuten auch
abgestimmt werden soll und der
zuständige Hubertus Heil spricht als
erstes dazu frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren die
demokratischen Parteien in diesem Haus
sich einig Putin darf diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnen wieder in der Ukraine noch bei
dem Versuch mit dem Einsatz von Gas als
Waffe unsere westlichen Gesellschaften
wirtschaftlich und sozial zu
destabilisieren denn sein Ziel ist es
erklärtermaßen mit dem Einsatz von Gas
als Waffe wirtschaftlich und soziale
Unruhen herbeizuführen die unsere
Solidarität mit der Ukraine brüchig
machen sollen das werden wir nicht
zulassen wir werden uns nicht spalten
lassen meine Damen und
und deshalb sind es fünf Dinge die sich
die Bundesregierung vorgenommen hat um
Deutschland in dieser wirtschaftlich und
soziale herausfordernden Zeit gut und
sicher durch diese Zeit zu führen
erstens die Sicherung der
Versorgungssicherheit die Anstrengung
dieser Bundesregierung vor allen Dingen
des Bundeskanzlers und meines Kollegen
Robert Habeck seit Beginn dieser
Regierung sind darauf ausgerichtet eben
dafür zu sorgen dass wir durch diesen
Winter kommen und genug Gas zur
Verfügung ist dass wir weder in die
gasnotlage 4 kommen noch rationieren
müssen und das scheint zu gelingen
zweitens durch Eingriffe in den Markt
den Strom und Gasmarkt mit den heute
beschlossenen Maßnahmen mit dem
Abwehrschirm gegen diesen Angriffskrieg
was die wirtschaftlichen Folgen betrifft
werden wir dafür sorgen dass für
Wirtschaft und Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher Gas und Strompreise in einem
erträglichen Maß gehalten werden
drittens mit dem Entlastungspaket den
Leistungspaketen von insgesamt 100
Milliarden Euro sorgen wir für gezielte
Entlastung von Menschen mit unteren und
mittleren Einkommen und viertens meine
Damen und Herren heute ist auch
beschlossen worden dass wir
Wirtschaftshilfen ausweiten werden um
vor allen Dingen kleine
mittelständischen Unternehmen die durch
gestiegene Produktionskosten in
Schieflage kommen sind oder bei denen
die Nachfrage wegbricht zu helfen und
fünftens meine Damen und Herren damit
bin ich bei dem Gesetzentwurf heute
unser Ziel ist und bleibt es dass wir
auch den deutschen Arbeitsmarkt die
deutschen Arbeitsplätze stabil und
robust durch diese Krise führen und
deshalb
habe ich entschieden als
Bundesarbeitsminister dass wir die
Verordnungsermächtigung der Deutsche
Bundestag uns noch bis 30 September
gegeben hat nutzen und den vereinfachten
zu
Kurzarbeit auch in diesem Winter
gewährleisten um Sicherheit zu geben für
die Unternehmen die in Schlagseite
kommen für die Beschäftigten die sich
Angst machen um ihre Arbeitsplätze wir
haben gestern im Kabinett zusätzlich
entschieden dass wir auch
Arbeitnehmerüberlassung das heißt
Leiharbeit abschirmen werden weil wir
Anzeichen haben dass da Menschen
entlassen werden können wenn wir sie
heute mit diesem Gesetz darum bitten als
Deutscher Bundestag in diesem Winter der
Bundesregierung alle
Verordnungsermächtigung bis zur Mitte
nächsten Jahres in die Hand zu geben
dann dann
damit wir Vorsorge treffen für
wirtschaftliche Eskalation ich hoffe
dass sie nicht von allen diesen
verordnungsermächtigen Gebrauch machen
werden aber klar ist meine Damen und
Herren Kurzarbeit hat in der
corona-pandemie dafür gesorgt dass wir
Millionen von Arbeitsplätzen sichern
konnten es hat geholfen dass Unternehmen
Fachkräfte an Bord halten könnten um
wieder durchzustatten es hat die
gesamtwirtschaftliche Nachfrage
stabilisiert und deshalb ist ganz klar
in Krisenzeiten gilt es Brücke zu bauen
und Sicherheit zu schaffen meine Bitte
ist diesem Hause gegenüber diesem
Gesetzentwurf zuzustimmen um Sicherheit
am Arbeitsmarkt zu schaffen putin wird
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen wie der
wirtschaftlich noch sozial noch
militärisch uns gegenüber meine Damen
und Herren und deshalb bitte ich Sie um
die wirtschaftlichen Unterstützung die
notwendig sind dankeschön
der Bundesminister für Arbeit und
Soziales Hubertus Heil hat hier für den
Gesetzentwurf geworben über den auch
dann die Abgeordneten abstimmen jetzt
gehen wir aber erst einmal in die
Aussprache und da hat Maximilian
mörseburg für die CDU CSU als erstes das
Wort sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen sowohl
die Pandemie als auch die Energiekrise
sind in der Lage Menschen im Land die
Politik und die Gesellschaft als Ganzes
bis zum Äußersten zu fordern das allein
sehr geehrter Herr Minister Heil
bedeutet aber nicht dass wir für die
beiden Krisen dieselben Werkzeuge nutzen
können denn auch wenn es gefühlt
ähnliche Situationen sind unterscheiden
sie sich insbesondere wirtschaftlich
deutlich voneinander im ersten Lockdown
mussten wir völlig gesunde Unternehmen
von einem Tag auf den anderen
dichtmachen lassen Millionen von
Arbeitnehmern werden innerhalb von
kürzester Zeit auf auf der Straße
gestanden wenn wir sie nicht vor allem
eben auch mit dem Kurzarbeitergeld
aufgefangen hätten heute hingegen finden
wir nach den zwei schwierigen Jahren oft
bereits angeschlagene Unternehmen vor
die eigentlich produzieren könnten aber
bei denen es sich nicht mehr lohnt
aufgrund der hohen Energiepreise die
sich einfach nicht mehr leisten können
und da so alles knapp wird werden die
Produkte die diese produzieren auch
immer rare und dann eben noch teurer um
diese Spirale zu durchbrechen dürfen wir
unsere Unternehmen jetzt auf keinen Fall
dicht machen lassen sie müssen also so
lange wie möglich offen gehalten werden
um den angebotsschock nicht noch weiter
zu beschleunigen also um die Nachfrage
eben auch weiter mit Produkten bedienen
zu können Unternehmen die wie Minister
Habig sagen würde einfach aufhören zu
produzieren dürfen aber gar keine
Kurzarbeit anmelden gestiegene
Energiepreise erfüllen eben nicht die
Voraussetzungen zum Anmelden von
Kurzarbeit das hat auch die öffentliche
Anhörung ganz deutlich gezeigt und ihnen
zeigt das es ist eben nicht dieselbe Art
von Notlage in der wir stecken wieder
rechtlich noch wirtschaftlich anstatt
auf die altenselben Rezepte zu setzen
haben sie ja eben auch heute eine Reihe
andere Maßnahmen verkündet sie wollen
200 Milliarden Euro Schulden machen um
einen Schirm über den Energiesektor zu
spannen sie wollen so die Preise senken
von ein paar Tagen hat der
Finanzminister noch betont dass eben
nicht jede Belastung abgefettet werden
kann heute Klang des anders am Ende
haben sie sich auf was geeinigt das ist
jetzt so aber dann stellt sich dann
stellt sich die Frage
ob diese 200 Milliarden Euro Schulden
nicht auch die bessere Lösung sind ob
wir damit nicht auch für den
Arbeitsmarkt besser für den Arbeitsmarkt
bessere Maßnahmen mit leisten die
Regierungsfraktion wollen zusätzlich
aber die Bundesregierung ermächtigen
wieder
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge zu
übernehmen und Kurzarbeit auch
Kurzarbeitergeld auch dann auszahlen
bevor Urlaub und Überstunden abgebaut
sind das klingt natürlich großzügig aber
die Frage die sich dann stellt wie haben
sie das finanziert der Blick in den
Haushaltsentwurf zeigt ja sie haben null
Euro für diese Maßnahmen eingestellt
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
auch die Rücklagen der Bundesagentur
sind aufgebraucht es wurde uns ja auch
noch mal eindrücklich aus der
Bundesagentur mitgeteilt sie wollen sie
wollen die Beiträge aus der
Arbeitslosenversicherung nutzen dafür
wird aber die Erhöhung auch 2,6 Prozent
sicherlich nicht ausreichen wir können
uns keine
schwindelerregend hohen Sozialbeiträge
leisten sie können uns ja zu diesem
Zeitpunkt noch nicht mal sagen wie viel
diese Maßnahmen Kosten werden sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren sie wissen
nicht einmal wie viel Leute von diesen
Maßnahmen profitieren werden das ist
einfach keine solide Grundlage um so
etwas heute zu beschließen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
wenn Sie das Kurzarbeitergeld wirklich
als Instrument in der Energiekrise
einsetzen wollen dann sollten Sie ein
krisenkurzarbeitergeld schaffen das
steuerfinanziert ist und das eben auch
im Haushalt mit Geld hinterlegt ist weil
die Rücklagen sind nicht mehr da
Kurzarbeitergeld per se meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren ist für die
cdu/csu ein herzensandliegen wir haben
es nicht nur den letzten Jahren
gemeinsam mit unserem Koalitionspartner
von der SPD genutzt um Deutschland durch
die Krisen zu steuern sondern wir haben
es selbst 1956 ins Gesetz geschrieben
deshalb stehen wir auch weiter zu diesem
Instrument vor dem aktuellen Hintergrund
werden wir aber eine Veränderung des
kurzarbeitergelds nämlich der Ausweitung
in der jetzigen Lage nicht zustimmen es
ist wirtschaftspolitisch einfach nicht
angezeigt und die Beiträge der
Arbeitslosenversicherung sind einfach
auch nicht Verfügungsmasse für ihre
Krisenpolitik wenn Sie ein Krisen
Kurzarbeitergeld schaffen wollen dann
hinterlegen Sie es mit Steuermitteln im
Haushalt dann können wir uns noch mal
überlegen ob wir Sie dabei unterstützen
vielen Dank
Maximilian Merseburg warnt hier vor
diesem Gesetzentwurf und der damit
verbundenen längeren vereinfachten
Zugangsmöglichkeit zum Kurzarbeitergeld
auch der Bundesrechnungshof hat schon
sich negativ dazu geäußert
[Applaus]
Präsidentin Herr Minister Kolleginnen
und Kollegen sehr geehrte Gäste
kurzarbeit ist ein bewährtes Instrument
stabilisiert in Krisenzeiten
nachweislich Beschäftigung das hat sich
schon in der Finanzkrise gezeigt und das
war auch so in Zeiten von Corona und das
gilt auch jetzt für die Krise nach dem
russischen Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
und dessen energiepolitischen folgen
dass Ihr Baby bezeichnet den
Arbeitsmarkt zwar im Moment noch als
robust aber das kann sich schnell ändern
wenn Produktion reduziert werden müssen
oder wenn Lieferketten Reisen und dann
ist es gut dass die Bundesregierung
schnell reagieren kann denn als
Kurzarbeitergeld hilft sofort
unmittelbar und das ist dann auch
wichtig für die Unternehmen
in der Anhörung am Montag haben
Wirtschaft und Gewerkschaften die
Gesetzentwurf einhellig begrüßt alle
wissen dass Krisenzeiten durch
Kurzarbeit abgefedert und überbrückt
werden können Beschäftigte werden nicht
arbeitslos und die Unternehmen wollen
auch ihre Beschäftigten in diesen
schwierigen Zeiten halten auch wegen dem
Fach und Arbeitskräftemangel in der
Anhörung wahr zu spüren dass alle
zumindest fast alle die Union eben nicht
an einem Strang ziehen und diese
Solidarität dass alle zusammenhalten ist
wichtig und wird dieser besonderen
Situation auch gerecht
bei der Anhörung wurden aber auch
Probleme angesprochen die wir im
Zusammenhang mit dem Kurzarbeitergeld
nicht aus dem Blick verlieren dürfen da
ist die Sorge der Bundesagentur für
Arbeiters eine erneut hohe Zahl an
Anträgen nicht bewältigt werden kann
weil die BA eben damit beschäftigt ist
noch die Abschlussprüfung aus der
corona-zeit zu absolvieren hier müssen
Änderungen im Verfahren oder sogar ein
neues Instrument ein Krisen
Kurzarbeitergeld diskutiert werden wenn
die Bundesagentur für Arbeit das so
deutlich sagt dann müssen wir das
natürlich auch ernst nehmen
und dann gibt es da auch die Regelung
dass ein Minijob bei Bezug von
kurzarbeitergeldanrechnungsfrei bleibt
diese Regelung überdeckt ein Problem und
zwar dass das Kurzarbeitergeld bei
kleinen Einkommen zu niedrig ist und
nicht zum Leben reicht hier gibt es
definitiv Handlungsbedarf mit dem wir
uns ernsthaft beschäftigen müssen
das war kurz der Blick nach vorne heute
aber geht es darum die Bundesregierung
handlungsfähig zu machen damit sie mit
dem Kurzarbeitergeld eine Brücke bauen
kann die den Unternehmen und den
Beschäftigten wenn es notwendig wird
wirklich hilft denn wir wollen natürlich
alles dafür tun um Entlassungen und
Arbeitslosigkeit zu verhindern die Union
hat gestern im Ausschuss dagegen
gestimmt hat es jetzt eben noch mal
gesagt ich kann es überhaupt nicht
verstehen und die die Argumente sind
extrem schwach und trotzdem hoffe ich
dennoch jetzt auf eine breite
Unterstützung vielen Dank
Beate Müller Gemmeke war das hier
zum
Kurzarbeitergeld nächster Redner ist
Hannes Gnauck er spricht für die
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
der Winter naht und man merkt ihnen auf
der Regierungsbank wird allmählich warm
ganz im Gegensatz zum Großteil der
Bevölkerung wir sehen mit der
Veränderung dieser
Verordnungsermächtigung beim
Kurzarbeitergeld den Auftakt ihr ihrer
kommenden Krisen und protestmanagements
in diesem Winter sie beschneiden hier
natürlich die Handlungsfähigkeit des
Bundestages da Weichenstellungen mit
einem Kostenvolumen dieser Dimension
eigentlich im zuständigkeits- und
Verantwortungsbereich der Legislative
und eben nicht der Exekutive liegen das
Budgetrecht liegt beim Parlament und
Frau Anke Eitner von der Bundesagentur
für Arbeit erklärte im Ausschuss für
Arbeit und Soziales noch in dieser Woche
das eine erneute massenhaft den
Anspruchnahme des Kurzarbeitergeldes wie
in den letzten zwei Jahren während ihrer
unverhältnismäßigen corona-maßnahmen
nicht zu bewältigen wären die Rücklagen
sind ja bereits jetzt aufgebraucht kurz
gesagt Sie haben gar nicht mehr das Geld
um diesen sozialen Schirm zu finanzieren
aber wenn kümmert es angesichts der
Inflationsrate noch bei ihnen in der
Bundesregierung offenbar niemanden und
zugestanden wir stehen vor solch großen
Verwerfungen das eine flexible
Handlungsfähigkeit der Regierung
notwendig sein wird zumindest da können
wir als afd-fraktion mitgehen und
natürlich ist der primäre Zweck des
ausgeweiteten Kurzarbeitergeldes die
Verhinderung von Massenarbeitslosigkeit
und das ist in einer Krise die oberste
Priorität der politischen Führung das
Kurzarbeitergeld ist allerdings
eigentlich dazu da um im Falle einer
kurzfristigen schlechten Auftragslage
die Arbeitnehmer vor dem Arbeitsverlust
zu schützen aber nicht dafür um alle
Unternehmen unseres Landes ob
wirtschaftlich arbeiten oder nicht zu
subventionieren
sie greifen hier auf eine neoliberale
Politik zurück meine Damen und Herren
die der Dimension der Lage überhaupt
nicht angemessen ist sie öffnen damit
den Missbrauch und negativer
Lenkungseffekte Tür und Tor während
Arbeitnehmer durch verringerten Lohn
steigende Inflation und andauernde
Steuerabgabe dennoch kaputt werden sie
können mit der Veränderung dieser
Regelung vielleicht über den Winter
hinweg unsere wirtschaftslandschaft
strukturell halbwegs am Leben halten
eine echte Lösung für das Sterben
unserer Industrienation ist es dennoch
nicht meine Damen und Herren
und hier liegt das viel grundlegendere
Problem sie haben sich über Jahrzehnte
mit einem Fokus auf Dienstleistung
grüner Energiewende und wird
außenwirtschaftlicher Einseitigkeit in
eine Lage manövriert in der unser Land
nun kurz vor dem Abgrund steht sie
können mit Kurzarbeitergeld die soziale
Frage in Deutschland vielleicht ein
wenig aufschieben lösen werden sie sie
allerdings nicht ganz im Gegenteil sie
wird sich in den kommenden Wochen und
Monaten bloß noch zuspitzen was wir hier
sehen ist das typische Handlungsmuster
vor allem von dieser von Verfehlung
getriebenen Bundesregierung die Problem
Zusammenhänge sind dermaßen komplex dass
die Krise zum Dauerzustand geworden ist
sie nutzen staatliche Instrumente die
ursprünglich für kurzfristige Notstände
vorgesehen waren und machen sie zum
permanenten Werkzeug ihres Verfalls
meines Managements das Krisenregime dass
ich in diesem Hause langsam anbahnt wird
sich jeder Beratung entziehen von uns
als parlamentarische Opposition ja
sowieso das haben bei Corona schon
gesehen aber auch der volksprotest
interessiert sie ja Frau bärburg im
nicht im geringsten und deshalb muss
sich der Protest der Bürger schleunigst
konzentrieren meine Damen und Herren
dazu möchte ich abschließend noch einmal
alle mit bachel aufrufen um am achten
Oktober mit uns als AFD hier in der
Hauptstadt als geeinter volksprotest auf
die Straße zu gehen insbesondere auch
jene die von Kurzarbeit betroffen sind
damit es nicht bei permanenter
Kurzarbeit grüner Deindustrialisierung
und Massenverarmung bleibt und damit die
Entscheidungsträger dieses Hohen Hauses
mal wieder an ihren Amtseid erinnert
werden denn in der Bundesrepublik meine
Damen und Herren in der Bundesrepublik
ist und bleibt der Souverän das deutsche
Volk vielen Dank
Hannes genau war das hat hier sich noch
mal für Demonstrationen ausgesprochen
dass Mark allerdings zum Beispiel dabei
Demonstration von Fridays for future
etwas anders klingen aber das nur eine
Vermutung Pascal Kuba spricht jetzt für
die FDP-Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das Kurzarbeitergeld ist ein
Erfolg es ist ein notwendiger Erfolg in
einer schwierigen Situation viele
Experten in anderen Ländern beneiden uns
um dieses Instrument es ermöglicht die
Wahrung und Sicherung der Existenz
vieler Arbeitsplätze auch wenn wir nicht
verschweigen dürfen dass es einhergeht
für viele mit Einkommensverlusten und
deshalb natürlich die Sorgen auf der
einen Seite mildert aber gleichzeitig
auch nicht jede Sorge beseitigen kann
und ich möchte auch darauf hinweisen
dass es ein Vorteil ist für Unternehmen
denn auch die Unternehmen können nach
der schwierigen Phase in der sie
Kurzarbeit der Geld beantragen mussten
mit ihren eingeübten und bewerten
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern sofort
den Schwung der dann vielleicht wieder
entsteht aber Arbeitsmarkt bzw in der
Wirtschaft die Entwicklung nutzen um
dann wieder Produkte auf den Markt zu
bringen und ich möchte mich ausdrücklich
bei denjenigen unter den
Unternehmerinnen Unternehmern bedanken
die aus eigenen Mitteln das
Kurzarbeitergeld aufgestockt haben das
ist keine Selbstverständlichkeit und das
sollte hier nicht unerwähnt bleiben
[Applaus]
was auch nicht unerwähnt bleiben sollte
sind die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
die diesen erhöhten
anstörung auf Kurzarbeitergeld die
erhöhten Zahlen anmeldungen für
Kurzarbeit bewältigt haben und der hohen
persönlichen Einsatz mit hoher
persönlicher Motivation und nur durch
diese Motivation der Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeiter der Bundesagentur für
Arbeit war es am Ende möglich auch
möglichst schnell die Hilfe zur
Verfügung zu stellen herzlichen Dank
dafür
besonders freut mich in diesem
Zusammenhang auch dass es auf unsere
Initiative hin gelungen ist dass wir
auch die Kurzarbeit gerade in der drei
Monaten jetzt zwischen 1 oktober und dem
31 Dezember dass wir da die Zeitarbeit
auch wieder mit in der Kurzarbeit
berücksichtigen können übrigens es wäre
vielleicht auch mal an der Zeit darüber
nachzudenken ob der Begriff Leiharbeit
für Zeitarbeiter noch angemessen ist
denn es sagt schon etwas aus über das
Bild der Menschen die in einem
sozialversicherungspflichtigen
Beschäftigungsverhältnis arbeiten wenn
wir Sie als Leiharbeiter bezeichnen ich
glaube hier sollten wir noch mal darüber
nachdenken
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
sollten aber auch nicht verschweigen
dass Kurzarbeit ein teures Instrument
ist es sind die genauen Zahlen liegen ja
noch nicht vor aber man darf davon
ausgehen schon um die 50 Milliarden Euro
plus
aufgewendet worden im Februar sagte der
Chef der Bundesagentur für Arbeit damals
Detlef Scheele das ist 46 Milliarden
Euro gewesen sein plus Steuergeld im
Jahr 2021 wohl von 18 Milliarden Euro es
ist ein teures Instrument es ist ein
notwendiges Instrument aber wir dürfen
nicht verschweigen dass da ein
erhebliche Arbeitsleistung der
MitarbeiterInnen Mitarbeiter und auch
der Unternehmen in den guten Zeiten
dahintersteckt überhaupt die Rücklagen
in der Arbeitslosenversicherung
aufzubauen und auch Dank an die
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler die
hier einspringen obwohl sie vielleicht
gar nicht persönlich von Kurzarbeit
betroffen sind eine große solidarische
Leistung dieser Gesellschaft alle helfen
zusammen ganz großartig herzlichen Dank
dafür
aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass die
Krise die wir bisher kannten im
Wesentlichen Corona mit dem bisherigen
Erfahrungen bei der Kurzarbeit sich
vielleicht in den nächsten Monaten noch
ganz anders gestalten wird deshalb ist
es wichtig dass wir hier die richtigen
Maßnahmen treffen die Bundesregierung
hat sich gerade darauf verständigt wie
die Energiepreise im Griff behalten
werden können das ist eine wichtige
Entscheidung weil es notwendig ist dass
wir natürlich auch die
Kostensteigerungen für die Unternehmen
im Blick behalten und auch da möchten
wir als FDP in dieser Koalition daran
erinnern dass wir unternehmen auch
dadurch entlasten können dass wir sie
nicht nur dauernd neu belasten und da
hat das Arbeitsrecht natürlich auch
seinen Anteil dran ich würde mich freuen
wenn wir bei der Nachweis Richtlinie
noch mal drauf schauen könnten dass wir
Chancen der Digitalisierung nutzen die
uns die EU auch einräumt das würde viele
Unternehmen entlasten und da wäre es
glaube ich angebracht an der Stelle noch
einmal zu prüfen ob wir hier nicht zu
Entlastungen kommen könnten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir kämpfen alle gemeinsam für die
Bewältigung der Krise der energiekrieg
Putins gegen die freie Welt gegen unsere
Volkswirtschaft gegen unsere
Gesellschaft wird keinen Erfolg haben
dafür steht diese Regierung solidarisch
mit den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern zusammen
wir schaffen auch diese Herausforderung
da bin ich zuversichtlich vielen Dank
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich grüße
Sie alle ganz herzlich am
Donnerstagnachmittag spüre die Frische
im Raum die jetzt sicherlich noch mal in
dieser Debatte hervorkommt und das Wort
erhält Jessica tatti für die Fraktion
DIE LINKE
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Beschäftigten
und Betrieben steht ein harter Winter
bevor die Unsicherheit ist groß und
deshalb stimmt die Linke dem
Gesetzentwurf zum Kurzarbeitergeld
selbstverständlich zu
das Minister Heil nutzen Sie dieses
Gesetz jetzt auch für Verbesserungen
greifen Sie doch einfach mal die sehr
guten Vorschläge meiner Fraktion auf zum
Beispiel die Einführung eines mindest
Kurzarbeitergeldes von 1.200 Euro für
Vollzeitkräfte oder die Erhöhung des
Kurzarbeitergeldes auf 90% von netto
also das wäre total sinnvoll bei diesen
krassen Preissteigerungen und nicht
zuletzt
es kann doch nicht sein dass Unternehmen
die Kurzarbeit in Anspruch nehmen
gleichzeitig horrende Boni an Manager
und hohe Dividenden an ihre Aktionäre
ausschütten das ist völlig unangemessen
und muss endlich unterbunden werden und
jetzt zuhören Herr mörseburg von der
Unionsfraktion denn derzeit kann das
Kurzarbeitergeld eben nicht mehr aus
Beiträgen finanziert werden sondern muss
aus Steuermitteln bezahlt das heißt von
der Allgemeinheit getragen werden die
Rücklagen der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
sind nach Corona schon lange verbraucht
während der Pandemie mussten weit über
20 Milliarden Euro aus Steuermitteln
zugeschossen werden und das war auch
richtig so weil damit Arbeitsplätze
erhalten wurden und deshalb wird das
auch weiterhin wichtig sein
denn diese Krise wären Ausgangspunkt der
völkerrechtswidrige Angriffskrieg war
ist eine politische Krise und deshalb
Pascal gruber ist die Finanzierung der
Kurzarbeit auch eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe
so unverzichtbar das Kurzarbeitergeld
auch ist noch besser wäre es natürlich
zu verhindern dass überhaupt wieder
massenhaft Beschäftigte in die
Kurzarbeit gehen müssen das ganze
Industriezweige ins Wanken geraten muss
verhindert werden die Chaostage der
Bundesregierung gasumlage ja jetzt
wieder nein Gaspreise Deckeln gestern
noch nein heute doch ja dieses Chaos der
Bundesregierung ist für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger für die Betriebe in den
Beschäftigte Angst um ihren Arbeitsplatz
haben und zumutbar wie viel Zeit ging
dadurch ins Land stoppen Sie die
Preisexplosion sichern sie die
Produktion mit einem wirksamen
gaspreisdeckel
Kolleginnen und Kollegen richten sie
Bundeskanzler Scholz doch bitte
herzliche Grüße von mir aus ich erwarte
nämlich von ihm dass er beim nächsten
Treffen der konzertierten Aktion wenn er
sich mit den Gewerkschaften und
Arbeitgeberverbänden trifft mal nachhakt
warum nutzen die Betriebe eigentlich die
Zeit von Kurzarbeit nicht viel stärker
für Weiterbildung ihrer Beschäftigten in
der Transformation die Fakten
Kurzarbeiter nahmen in der Pandemie
wesentlich Selter immer an
Weiterbildungen teil als andere
Beschäftigte und wenn doch
Weiterbildungen stattfanden dann für
Beschäftigte mit Hochschulabschluss neun
Mal häufiger als für Leute die gar
keinen Abschluss haben und das ist doch
wirklich eine eine wirklich
katastrophale Bilanz
also hier ist noch massiv was zu tun
sofort anfangen könnten sie im übrigen
Herr Heil mit der Stärkung der
Mitbestimmung mit der Stärkung von
Betriebs- und Personalräten denn dort wo
es Betriebsräte gibt finden auch mehr
Weiterbildungen statt auch für die
Kurzarbeit und deshalb fangen Sie damit
endlich an
die Forderung von Jessica Tati der
arbeitsmarktpolitischen Sprecherin der
Linken auf sie antworten wird jetzt Jens
Park für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Abgeordnete
fangen wir mal mit der guten Nachricht
an unser Arbeitsmarkt ist robust
trotz drohender Rezession sind wieder
mehr Menschen in Arbeit trotz der realen
Gefahr einer gasmangellade suchen
Unternehmen Händeringen Fachkräfte in
diesem Land ohne diese dunklen Wolke am
Horizont werden wir heute voller
Zuversicht auf einen ungetrübten
Arbeitsmarkt schauen aber wegen dieses
getrübten Ausblicks verlängern wir hier
und heute die Verordnungsermächtigung
für die Sonderregelungen des
Kurzarbeitergeldes dem erfolgreichsten
kriseninstrument in der corona-pandemie
und das ist richtig so dass es richtig
so weil dieser Gesetzentwurf den
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmern und
den Unternehmen Sicherheit und
Verlässlichkeit für die Zukunft gibt mit
dieser Verordnungsermächtigung machen
wir den Arbeitsmarkt weiterhin
krisenfest
in der corona-pandemie haben wir gesehen
was die Sonderregelungen das
Kurzarbeitergeldes können in dieser
bisher schwersten Wirtschaftskrise der
Nachkriegszeit haben über 5 Millionen
Menschen durch die Sonderregelungen des
Kurzarbeitergeldes ihren Job behalten
können
und die Kritiker der Sonderregelung wir
haben es ja gerade aufgehört Fragen dann
immer zu welchem Preis ja es hat die
Reserven der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
aufgebraucht ja es hat viel Geld
gekostet insgesamt über 45 Milliarden
auch wenn wir die konkrete Zahlen noch
nicht haben aber in der Anhörung am
Montag zu diesem Gesetzentwurf hat die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit noch einmal
ganz klar gesagt was es uns gekostet
hätte wenn wir diese Regelung nicht
gehabt hätten
wer in Kurzarbeit ist der braucht
monatlich bekommt monatlich
Unterstützung in Höhe von ca 38 Euro wer
aber arbeitslos wird muss mit 1.850 Euro
aus der Arbeitslosenversicherung
unterstützt werden das heißt ohne
Kurzarbeitergeld wäre diese Krise mehr
als doppelt so teuer geworden und dabei
reden wir noch nicht über dieser
wichtigen sozialen Folgekosten und
volkswirtschaftlichen denn was das mit
dem einzelnen macht was es für Familien
bedeutet wenn man arbeitslos wird welche
Sorgen und Probleme dann verbunden ist
das lässt sich nicht in eures ausdrücken
und auch von den immer wieder an die
Wand gemalten Schreckenszenarien beim
Kurzarbeitergeld ist kein einziges
eingetreten nein es lässt sich keine
Entwöhnung der Menschen von der Arbeit
feststellen nein es gab nach der
corona-pandemie keine zombie-firmen die
einfach in Insolvenz gegangen sind und
nein es gibt auch keine Anzeichen dafür
dass der Strukturwandel verschleppt
wurde ganz im Gegenteil dass wir ein
robusten Arbeitsmarkt haben dass wir
eine
schnell Erholung der Beschäftigten
Zahlen haben das ist der Verdienst des
Kurzarbeitergeldes so sieht gute
Arbeitsmarktpolitik aus
und deswegen ist es folgerichtig heute
der Bundesregierung weiterhin die
Möglichkeit zu geben diese Instrumente
zu nutzen und es ist vollkommen klar
dass das nicht ausreicht dass das ein
Baustein in der Krisenbekämpfung ist um
nichts anderes geht es doch natürlich
brauchen wir flankierende
Wirtschaftshilfen um Insolvenzen zu
verhindern natürlich braucht es
entlastungspakete und einem vor allem
eine energiepreisdeckel für Gas und
Strom sowie heute von der
Bundesregierung auf beschlossen wurde
und wir brauchen auch
Daseinsvorsorge in öffentlicher Hand
wieder Fall uniper zeigt und natürlich
müssen wir auch krisenprofiteuren die
Pflicht nehmen am besten mit einer
übergewinnsteuer
und ich will noch eins kurz sagen zur
Kritik der CDU von der mörseburg
natürlich rechtfertigen gestiegende
Preise beim Gas keine Kurzarbeit das ist
Betriebsrisiko aber liefer Engpässe
Tunes und auch die sind doch nicht
ausgeschlossen durch den Krieg in der
Ukraine und auch eine gasmangellage
würde es tun und natürlich ist das kurz
aber der kann Dauerlösung aber Krisen
sollen es auch nicht sein solange es die
Krise gibt reagieren wir auch was die
CDU macht ist an der Stelle aber
vollkommen unklar im Fachausschuss haben
sie dagegen gestimmt im
Haushaltsausschuss haben sich enthalten
sie ihr Licht dann durch die Krise und
ich bin gespannt was sie gleich tun
werden ich kann Ihnen nur sagen stimmen
sie zu weil mit diesen vorigen
Gesetzentwurf machen wir den
Arbeitsmarkt krisenfest dass es gut so
geht Politik die den Menschen hilft
herzlichen Dank
wie können die Unternehmen in dieser
schwierigen Zeit unterstützt werden
Menschen vor Arbeitslosigkeit geschützt
werden ohne zu hohe Sozialausgaben zu
haben darüber diskutieren hier die
Abgeordneten als nächstes Axel knörig
für die Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
zuhören und zuhören
zunächst möchte ich ganz klar
feststellen dass Kurzarbeitergeld hat
uns während der Pandemie einen guten
Dienst erwiesen wir haben in Deutschland
keine massenhafte Arbeitslosigkeit
gesehen der Arbeitsmarkt ist stabil
geblieben das war schlichtweg gut für
die Beschäftigten denn sie wussten dass
ihre Arbeitsplätze abgesichert werden
zugleich war es gut für die Unternehmen
die Arbeitgeber konnten ihre Mitarbeiter
nicht nur halten sondern hatten nach der
Pandemie die Möglichkeit wieder
durchzustarten es war da ja richtig den
Zugang zum Kurzarbeitergeld zum
vereinfachen und weitere
Sonderregelungen einzuführen
dennoch war schon damals klar dass das
Instrument eigentlich nicht für solche
Fälle gedacht ist die Ressourcen der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit und zu lassen
ihrer Hauptaufgaben beansprucht
trotzdem war das Kurzarbeitergeld der
richtige Weg nun haben wir aber eine
völlig andere Situation
wir waren in der Pandemie gezwungen die
Wirtschaft allgemein herunterzufahren
deshalb war das breit angelegte
Kurzarbeitergeld ein gutes Konzept jetzt
müssen wir viel mehr verhindern dass
Bestand bestimmte Branchen lahmgelegt
werden wir brauchen zielgerichtete
Hilfen für energieintensive Unternehmen
liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
ampelsicheren sich wenn sie das
Kurzarbeitergeld als Mittel gegen die
hohen Energiekosten einsetzen wollen ihr
Weg ist nicht nur einfach falsch
errichtet auch Schaden an Sie stellen
sich das Kurzarbeitergeld als
Liquiditätshilfe für kleinere und
mittlere Unternehmen vor aber diese
Vorstellung geht schlichtweg an der
Realität vorbei fakt ist
das Kurzarbeitergeld dient dazu
beschäftigungsausfälle zu begrenzen und
ich möchte sie Herr Minister und die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Koalition
daran erinnern wir haben derzeit in
Deutschland 1,9 Millionen unbesetzte
Stellen wie können Sie das Vergessen für
seine eigentlichen Aufgabe wird das
Kurzarbeiter Geld auf weiter benötigt
aber ist doch kein Instrument für jede
Krise
zeitlich überschaubare Ausfälle aus
konjunkturellen Gründen müssen natürlich
auch in Zukunft aufgefangen werden daran
rüttelt auch niemand statt die
Sonderregeln zu verlängern muss unser
Ziel doch nun sein möglichst viele
Betriebe am Laufen zu halten unser
Mittelstand der ruft doch seit Wochen
und Monaten um Hilfe aber von ihnen
kommt keine Antwort
im Herbst und im Winter das werden wir
erleben wird es zu umfangreichen
Betriebsschließung kommen können da geht
es nicht um ein temporäres pausieren wie
das sehr Herbig sagte sondern um das
dauerhafte Verschwinden von Unternehmen
am Markt sorgen sie endlich dafür dass
die Produktion am Laufen bleibt und
unsere Unternehmen und Arbeitnehmer
weiterarbeiten können
sie wissen es
sie müssen es und Frau Nahles weiß es
auch der finanzielle Spielraum der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit die es
aufgebraucht das Kurzarbeitergeld müssen
Sie in Zukunft aus Steuermitteln
finanzieren oder neue Schulden aufnehmen
müssen keine gute Perspektive in der
Folge wird die hohe Inflation weiter
angeheizt die Preise steigen und die
Krise verschärft sich noch mehr wenn Sie
diesen Weg weitergehen werden sie
politisch scheitern scheitern werden
aber auch tausende von Unternehmen und
ihre beschäftigen Beschäftigten und das
wollen wir nicht verkraften wir fordern
vom Bundesarbeitsministerium seit über
einem Jahr das Kurzarbeitergeld
weiterzuentwickeln ganz besonders muss
dabei auch Qualifizierung und
Weiterbildung berücksichtigt werden das
wurde in den Phasen der Kurzarbeit
bislang nicht ausreichend umgesetzt wir
müssen noch unsere Beschäftigten das
richtige Rüstzeug mitgeben damit Sie
auch in Zukunft den Wandel der
Arbeitswelt bestehen können
und das ist nicht unser O-Ton das ist
der O-Ton der Bundesagentur sie waren
sogar davor dass sie Kurzarbeit
notwendige Transformationsprozesse in
Betrieben verhindert hier hätten schon
lange Lösungen entwickelt werden müssen
und liebe Kollegen es ist deutlich
geworden wir brauchen in dieser Krise
neue Konzepte um den Arbeitsmarkt auf
Kurs zu halten dabei müssen wir die
langfristigen Trends darum im Auge
behalten und vor allen Dingen den Wandel
des Arbeitsmarktes der Arbeitswelt nicht
verschlafen und ganz akut müssen doch
unsere Betriebe bei den hohen
Energiekosten unterstützt werden und sie
machen heute das Gegenteil sie
zweckentfremden und überladen das
Kurzarbeitergeld und den können wir
nicht zustimmen um das Kurzarbeitergeld
zu enthalten lehnen wir Ihren
Gesetzesentwurf ab danke für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
war das und damit können wir schon zum
vorletzten Redner hier in dieser Debatte
bevor dann die Abgeordneten darüber
abstimmen ob auch in Zukunft verlängert
das vereinfachten Zugang zum
Kurzarbeitergeld gibt bis zum Mitte den
des kommenden Jahres Wolfgang streckmann
Kuhn spricht jetzt oder auch Herr
mörseburg warum sie das Gesetz ablehnen
ist mehr als dünn und wirklich überhaupt
nicht nachvollziehbar
an einem Punkt haben sie recht wir sind
in einer anderen ökonomischen Situation
als zum Beginn der corona-krise zu
Beginn der corona-krise war das
Kurzarbeitergeld das zentrale Mittel aus
den Gründen die wir alle kennen jetzt
ist es ein Mittel aber ein wichtiges
Mittel wir stehen vor einer drohenden
Rezession aufgrund eines preisschocks
der verursacht worden ist durch den
Angriffskrieg von Putin
und darauf müssen wir reagieren eine
Rezession fällt nicht vom Himmel sondern
wir sind da handlungsfähig und wir
können dagegen angehen die
Energieversorgung muss sichergestellt
werden da ist die Bundesregierung seit
Dezember letzten Jahres dran und die
Energiespeicher sind gefüllt wir
entlasten die Menschen ganz wichtiger
Punkt und es sind ja noch nicht mal alle
entlastungspakete umgesetzt das läuft
also wir machen Unterstützung für die
kleinen und mittleren Unternehmen und
sonst für die Wirtschaft das hat heute
die Bundesregierung beschlossen und auch
mit finanziellen Mitteln hinterlegt das
ist sehr gut
die gasumlage brauchen wir nicht
einzuführen weil wir haben das
finanziell anders geregelt ganz im
Gegenteil zu ihren Forderungen zu
Ablehnung der gasumlage das ist gut dass
die gasumlage weg ist und dass die
Gegenfinanzierung gesichert ist
und es ist gut dass jetzt noch mal
konkretisiert worden ist dass wir in die
preismärkte einsteigen und gucken dass
wir einen gaspreisdecke und einen
stromdeckel hinkriegen und auch das ist
sinnvoll
und wir sind vor der vor einer Rezession
und die 200 Milliarden Euro die die
Bundesregierung heute vorgeschlagen hat
die wir ja erst noch bearbeiten müssen
im Bundestag haben das Zeug dazu dass es
ein regelrechtes Konjunkturprogramm sein
kann und auch das ist in der jetzigen
Situation richtig weil wir müssen ja
nicht nur auf das Angebot gucken bei so
einem preisschopf sondern auch auf die
Nachfrage und sicherstellen dass die
Nachfrage auch sichergestellt wird und
auch das macht die Bundesregierung genau
richtig
so und wir wissen die Arbeitsmärkte sind
sehr robust und es ist nicht mal klar ob
eine schwache Rezession überhaupt auf
die Arbeitsmärkte durchschlägt so warum
macht das Gesetz aber trotzdem Sinn
aus zwei Gründen erstens und das ist
noch gar nicht gesagt worden Corona ist
noch nicht vorbei die herbstwelle läuft
und nimmt zunehmend an Fahrt auch und
wir wissen nicht wie heftig das in
diesem Herbst und Winter noch wird und
darauf müssen wir vorbereitet sein
und der zweite Punkt ist wir sind nicht
hilflos gegen der ökonomischen
Entwicklung aber die Entwicklung ist so
schwierig vorherzusehen und auch die
prognoseinstrumente der ökonomischen
Institute sind da relativ unklar ist
kann sein bei allen Anstrengungen die
wir gemeinsam machen das ist doch
heftiger wird und auch darauf müssen wir
vorbereitet sein und deswegen ist es
eine Verordnungsermächtigung damit es im
Fall des Falles schnell die
Bundesregierung reagieren kann damit wir
Arbeitsplätze sichern können und das ist
genau der richtige Weg und dem sollten
alle demokratischen Parteien hier
zustimmen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und die letzte Rednerin in der Debatte
ist Natalie public sie sitzt für die
Sozialdemokraten im Ausschuss für Arbeit
und Soziales
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen verehrte
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer es wurde
heute von einem Teil der
ParlamentarierInnen Parlamentarier
deutlich aber vor allem wurde das diese
Woche in der öffentlichen Anhörung
seitens der Expertinnen und Experten aus
den Gewerkschaften von den
Wirtschaftsverbänden von der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit aus der
Wissenschaft deutlich dass
Kurzarbeitergeld ist und war eine
wesentliche Stütze die uns durch
Krisenzeiten führt und deswegen ist es
richtig dass wir das heute hier
verlängern
Beschäftigung zu fördern und
Arbeitsplätze gerade in Krisenzeiten zu
sichern das ist der Kern
sozialdemokratischer Politik und genau
dafür sorgen wir heute mit der
Verlängerung
drei Jahre corona-pandemie und die
bisherigen folgende schrecklichen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskriegs
Russlands auf die Ukraine haben unsere
Wirtschaft und unseren Arbeitsmarkt
nicht in den Ruinen getrieben
das sieht man auch zum Beispiel bei mir
zu Hause in Südhessen dort konnten wir
wegen des Kurzarbeitergeldes zahlreiche
Unternehmen am Industrie- und
Dienstleistungsstandort halten und
Beschäftigung sichern
Millionen Arbeitsplätze konnten und
können durch die Kurzarbeit erhalten
werden das sind nicht nur Zahlen das
sind Menschen dahinter stehen Familien
dass dahinter stehen Existenzen die
davor bewahrt werden konnten mitten in
einer wirtschaftlichen Ausnahmesituation
in Arbeitslosigkeit zu geraten und eine
in eine ungewisse Zukunft zu schauen und
das ist auch wichtig hierbei zu betonen
aber es ist eben nicht nur die
Perspektive aus seitens der
Beschäftigten dafür dass Kurzarbeit ein
erfolgsinstrument ist für uns als
Gesamtgesellschaft ist Kurzarbeit
wesentlich günstiger als die
Finanzierung von Arbeitslosigkeit für
unsere Unternehmen stellt Kurzarbeit
sicher dass Sie sich schnell von Krisen
erholen können und handlungsfähig
bleiben weil sie gute Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeiter eben nicht gehen lassen
müssen es sind viele Instrumente die wir
gerade in diesen Krisenzeiten auf dem
Weg bringen es sind preisbremsen das
sind entlastungspakete es sind der 12
Euro Mindestlohn das sind des Bürgergeld
das wir auf dem Weg bringen werden und
viele viele andere Maßnahmen die wir
derzeit tätigen die uns alle zusammen
durch diese Krise und diesen Winter
führen werden und so zu tun als würde
die Bundesregierung gar nichts tun ich
schlichtweg falsch
und Herr knörike ich wundere mich
tatsächlich was sie hier vorgetragen
haben denn die Regelungen zu
Qualifizierung in der Kurzarbeit haben
wir in der großen Koalition gemeinsam
noch in der letzten Legislaturperiode
auf den Weg gebracht und so zu tun als
gäbe es die nicht ist ebenfalls falsch
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir leben gerade in Zeiten
in denen viele politische Kräfte und
gerade hier an meiner rechten Seite
gerne dieses Land der Boden sehen würden
die mit politischen Kräften und
Kriegsverbrechern zusammenarbeiten die
lieber Gas sinnlos verbrennen statt das
nach Europa zu schicken
doch bei all den Schwierigkeiten und bei
all den Herausforderungen die wir
zusammen zu meistern haben und bei all
den dich inhaltlichen Differenzen die
wir unter der demokratischen Parteien um
den das in dem Ringen um den richtigen
Weg bin ich fest davon überzeugt dass
wir als Gesellschaft und als Demokratie
stärker sind als die Kriegsverbrecher
dieser Welt und der alles dafür tun
sollten diese Gesellschaft
zusammenzuhalten vielen Dank für Ihre
aufmerksam
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den von den
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur
Anpassung der Verordnungsermächtigung
beim Kurzarbeitergeld und anderer
Regelungen der Ausschuss für Arbeit und
Soziales empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache 37/21
den Gesetzentwurf der Fraktionen SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP auf
Drucksache 34 94 anzunehmen ich bitte
diejenigen die dem Gesetzentwurf
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen das
ist DIE LINKE SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP wer stimmt dagegen das ist die
cdu/csu wer enthält sich das ist die AFD
der Gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
Beratung angenommen wir kommen zur
dritten Beratung und Schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben dass es wiederum die Linke SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP wer stimmt
dagegen das ist die cdu/csu-fraktion und
wer enthält sich das ist die AFD damit
ist der Gesetzentwurf endgültig
angenommen so das war also dann die
Abstimmung zum Kurzarbeitergeld da wird
hier auch noch mal applaudiert